So in this lesson, we'll look at an important question
in switch design which is how much buffering do routers
and switches need? It's fairly well known that routers and
switches do need packet buffers to accommodate for statistical multiplexing.
But it's less clear how much packet buffering is really
necessary. Now given that queuing delay is really the only
variable part of packet delay on the internet, you'd think
we'd know the answer to this question already. And for
quite some time there have been some well understood rules
of thumb but it turns out that we've recently revisited
this question and come up with some different answers. So
let's first look at the universally applied rule of thumb. Now
for the sake of the examples in this lesson, I'm
going to use routers and switches
interchangeably because it doesn't really matter.
All that matters here is that we have a network
device that's a store and forward packet device. That, has the
capability of storing a frame or a packet and
then later sending it on. So let's suppose that we
have a path between a source and a destination,
and the round-trip propagation delay is 2T and the capacity
to bottleneck link is C. Now the commonly held
view is that this router needs a buffer of 2T
times C. It should be clear why this rule
of thumb exists. C is the capacity to the bottleneck
link in say, bits per second and T is the time of units second, so this works
out to bits, and the meaning of this quantity is simply the number of bits that
could be outstanding along this path at any
given time. It effectively represents the maximum amount
of outstanding data that could be on this
path between the source and destination at any time.
Now this rule of thumb guideline was mandated
in many backbone and edge routers for many years.
It appears in RFCs and ITF Architectural guidelines and
it has major consequences for router design. Simply because
this can be a lot of router memory and
memory can be expensive. The other thing of course
is that the bigger these buffers, not only the
bigger the cost but also the bigger the queuing
delay that could exist at any given router. And
hence, the more delay the interactive traffic may experience
and the more delay that feedback about congestion will
experience. The longer these delays are, the longer it
will take for the source to hear about congestion
that might exist in the network. Now to understand
why this guideline is incorrect, let's first re-derive the
rule of thumb a bit more formally and then we'll
understand why it does not always apply in practice.